my work ahead will be guided by the
three principles realism unity and
partnership we need partners we need to
be united and you need to act in the
real world so I want to support of the
Member State to give a fresh impulse to
the Foreign Affairs Council and when
meetings must be the place where our
collective efforts come together to
promote a more effective EU foreign
policy today in the council we have been
dealing with current affairs which as
you know are the most pressing it items
on the international agenda we have been
dealing with Memorandum of Understanding
signed between Libya and Turkey we
discussed this and it's a very clear
from our discussion that this document
raises major concerns we express our
solidarity and our support to Greece and
Cyprus and we will continue doing that I
personally raised Iran because on Friday
we had the meeting of the Joint
Commission of the jcpoa Friday in Vienna
shared by the secretary-general of the
European external Action Service we show
that all participants stand behind the
agreement and want to preserve it
this unanimous position is for us very
important all participants stand behind
the agreement and want to preserve it
Bolivia as you know is part of a wider
worrying situation in Latin America on
the last five years it hasn't been any
high-level meeting summit between
European Union and Latin American
countries anything this has to be
correct corrected and addressing this
will be one of the my priorities during
my mandate and one thing is clear we
cannot have a strategy for Africa
without Africa this has to be something
that responds to an ownership among
Europeans but mainly with the Africans
under the request of several member
states we have agreed to launch the
preparatory work for a global sanctions
regime to address serious human rights
violations which will be the European
Union equivalent of the so-called
Magnitsky act of the United States